Çeviri: Sessenol Projesi
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
(Müzik çalıyor)
Merhaba ben Mine.
Koda Köy Okulları Değişim Ağı Derneği
Kurucu Genel Koordinatörü'yüm.
Köy okulları değişim ağı fikri
genellikle hep dezavantajlarıyla
gündeme gelen köy okullarının
aslında eğitim için çok da
büyük fırsatlar içerdiğini
düşünmemizle ortaya çıktı.
Bir grup eğitim gönüllüsü ve
köy öğretmenleri olarak bir araya geldik.
İki temel hedefimiz var.
Biri; köy öğretmenlerini güçlendirmek,
ikincisi de; köy okulları için örnek
eğitsel uygulamalar ortaya çıkarmak.
Bu amaçla köy okullarında
hem örnek atölyeler yapıyoruz.
Ayda bir sıklıkla hafta sonları
çocuklarla atölyelerimiz var.
Onun dışında gönüllü
köy öğretmenlerini bir araya getirip
onlarla öğretmen buluşmaları düzenliyoruz.
Öğretmen buluşmaları da öğretmenlerin
hem motivasyonunu yükseltmek,
hem de onların kişisel ve
mesleki gelişimlerini desteklemek için.
Bütün bu çalışmalar sonucunda eğitimde
fırsat eşitsizliğinin daha az olduğu
ve köy okullarının hem
Türkiye'de, hem dünyada
daha iyi bir eğitim için yeni bir vizyon
ortaya çıkardığı bir dünya hayal ediyoruz.
Ben şimdi bugün size kendimden çok fazla
bahsetmek istemiyorum aslında.
Daha çok köy okulları
üzerine konuşmak istiyorum.
Kendimden bahsetmeyi çok sevmiyorum
belki biraz karakter meselesi,
belki biraz onun da ötesinde
son zamanlarda
ben beni çok heyecanlandıran
şeyleri insanlara anlatırken
aslında onları heyecanlandıran şeylerin
farklı şeyler olduğunu ya da
odaklarının başka bir yere
kaydığını görüyorum.
Mesela ben onlara, Samsun'un bir
köyünde tanıştığım Bulut'u anlatıyorum.
Bulut, deniz canlılarını öğrendikten sonra
ahtapotlara şiir yazmaya
başlamış bir çocuk.
Ya da Muş'un dağ köyünde tanıştığım,
beraber köy maketi yaparken o makete
metrobüs yerleştiren
Yasenir'i anlatıyorum.
Yasenir'e sormuştum o zaman;
- Nasıl, neden metrobüs
koydun bu köye diye?
Hocam eski köylere yeni âdetler
geliyor artık siz de demişti.
Yasenir'i anlatıyorum insanlara,
ama şeyi fark ediyorum insanların
en çok takıldığı nokta;
ya böyle genç bir kadın
28 yaşındayım aslında
16 -17 gibi gözüksem de çoğu kişiye.
Bu kadar genç bir kadın,
gidiyor köy köy dolaşıyor,
bir de Harvard'ları falan bitirmiş,
işi gücü yok mu bunun,
ailesi mi zengin falan diye düşünüyorlar.
Bazen açık açık söylüyorlar,
bazen ben hissediyorum bunları.
İşim gücüm var, hatta çok işim gücüm
varmış gibi hissediyorum.
Bir ömür bu işi gücü bitirmeye nasıl
yetecek bilmiyorum gerçekten.
Onun dışında ne çok akıllıyım ne çok
cesurum zengin de değilim,
açta açıkta değilim
ama zengin de değilim.
Ve buradan aslında size söyleyebileceğim,
kendi hayatıma dair söyleyebileceğim
tek şey sanırım ben, gönlümün
beni çektiği yere doğru gidiyorum.
Kendi yoluma doğru gidiyorum
ve bunun için çok mutluyum.
Umarım sizler de kendi yollarınızı bulur
ve o yollara gidersiniz.
Benim kendi hayatımdan sizlere
aktarabileceğim en önemli şey sanırım bu.
Bunun ötesinde ben bugün
dediğim gibi size köy okullarını ve
kendi köydeki deneyimlerimi
aktarmak için buraya geldim.
Ve bunun yapmanın en iyi yolu
ne olabilir diye düşündüm
ve size bir masal yazdım.
Şimdi size bir masal anlatacağım.
Kalbinizin özellikle biraz çocuk tarafını
açıp beni dinlerseniz çok mutlu olurum.
Şöyle bir saniyenizi rica ediyorum.
Başlıyorum.
Bir varmış, bir yokmuş...
Günlerden birinde, zamanlardan birinde
güzel mi güzel bir ülke varmış.
Öyle güzel ülkeymiş ki bu;
bir tarafı dağ, bir tarafı deniz,
bir tarafı yemyeşil ormanlar,
bir tarafı sapsarı bozkırlarmış.
Üzerinden geçen kuşlar hayran kalırmış,
bakarlarmış ne de güzel
bir ülke bu derlermiş,
gitmek istemezlermiş,
uçmak istemezlermiş bu ülkeden.
Ama masal bu ya
bir gariplik varmış ülkede.
Bu ülkenin tam ortasından beyaz,
sağlam mı sağlam,
uzun mu uzun bir çit geçermiş.
Bu ülkede yaşayan insanlar bu çitin bir
tarafına kent, bir tarafına köy derlermiş.
Çitin kent tarafı da
kalabalık mı kalabalıkmış.
Sabah olduğunda insanlar
çil yavrusu gibi sokaklara dağılırlarmış.
Büyük makinelere binerlermiş,
giderlermiş, yola çıkarlarmış
genelde bir saat.
Sonra vardıklarında
derin bir nefes alırlarmış iş yerine.
Egsoz, sigara dumanı, toz...
Sonra otururlarmış parlak
ekranların başına çalışmaya başlarlarmış.
Bir saat, iki saat, üç saat,
dört, beş altı, yedi, sekiz...
Sonra tekrar binerlermiş makinelerine,
etrafta grinin farklı tonlarını izleyerek,
kornaların ahenkli müziği eşliğinde
kat kat yuvalarından
bir deliğe girerlermiş.
Şatafatlı binalar, büyük sahneler,
orkestralar varmış bu şehirde.
Ama çoğu gidemezmiş buralara.
Çünkü ne vakitleri varmış,
ne de ceplerinde yeterince altınları.
Dev çilekleri, dev tavukları varmış,
ama lezzetleri yokmuş.
Ama onlar yine de
her akşam uykuya dalarken,
bir gün o şatafatlı
binalara gidebilecekleri,
ceplerinde daha fazla
altının olacağı bir günün
hayalini kurarken uykuya dalarlarmış.
Çitin öbür tarafına ise köy derlermiş.
Köyde yürürken tanıdık bir insan
görmeden yürüyemezmişsiniz bile.
Muhabbeti de bolmuş buranın
dedikodusu da,
sevgisi de bolmuş, şiddeti de.
Etraf renklerle bezeliymiş.
Bazen o kadar sessiz olurmuş ki
kulaklarınızı açtığınızda ağaçların,
böceklerin fısıltılarını
duyabilirmişsiniz.
Bazen çok erken kalkarmış insanlar
daha güneş bile doğmadan,
giderlermiş tarlalarda çalışırlarmış.
Sıcak demeden, yorgunluk nedir bilmeden.
Sonra kış gelmeden önce odun,
tezek ararlarmış etrafta yakacak.
Alırlarmış bulamazlarsa
korkarlarmış, dua ederlermiş;
don olmasın bu kış,
ekinler ziyan olmasın diye.
Çoğu zaman insanlar, köydeki insanlar
çitin öbür tarafını düşünürmüş.
O karşı taraftaki
şatafatlı binalara bakarlar,
makinalara bakarlar iç geçirirlermiş.
Bir gün orada, onlarda küçük bir deliğe
sahip olmanın hayalini kurarlarmış.
İşte bu ülkede, bu çitin kent tarafından
köy tarafına geçen pek insan yokmuş,
geçenlere de deli derlermiş.
Bu köy tarafından kent tarafına
geçense çok fazla kişi varmış.
Çok fazla kişi varmış ama
yine masal bu ya
gidenlerin çoğu şehrin
dipsiz sokaklarında kaybolurlarmış.
Kaybolmayan yok muymuş?
Varmış elbette ama yine
sayıları üçü beşi geçmezmiş.
İşte bu masalın içindeki bu köyde
Meryem adında güzel mi güzel,
kestane renkli saçlı, gök mavisi gözlü
Meryem adında bir kız çocuğu yaşarmış.
Meryem ağaçlara tırmanır, duvardan
düşer, tarlalarda çalışırken
bir gün büyümüş ve o büyük gün gelmiş.
Köy okulunun kapısından geçeceği gün.
Meryem artık gidecek,
tahta sıralara oturacak,
sayıların ve harflerin
gizemini öğrenecekmiş.
Meryem gitmiş okula,
her gün tahta sıralara oturmuş.
Doğru yanlış demeden
şekiller karalamış defterine, çalışmış.
Öğretmeni ne zaman, büyüyünce ne olmak
istersin diye sorsa; doktor dermiş.
Ben insanlara iyilik yapmak isterim.
Gel zaman git zaman,
Meryem büyümüş
karne alma vakti gelmiş.
Sevinçle koşmuş eve.
Gidince bir de ne görsün,
düğün dernek kurulmuş,
o gelmeden önce aile meclisi oturmuş,
Meryem'i emmi oğluna
vermeye karar vermişler.
Meryem önce eş olmuş sonra anne.
Meryem o gece mavi önlüğünü ütülemiş,
katlamış ve dolabının
en üst rafına yerleştirmiş.
Meryem bazen gecenin
en karanlık olduğu zamanlarda kalkar,
camın kenarına gider, açar,
usulca karıncaları
bile uyandırmadan ağlar ağlarmış.
Meryem'in on çocuğu olmuş,
hepsinin birincisi Hasan.
Hasan'ın da anası Meryem gibi
kestane rengi saçları,
gök mavisi gözleri varmış.
Ağaçlara tırmanır, duvardan düşer,
tarlada hasat yaparken o da büyüyüvermiş.
Büyük gün gelmiş girmiş
köy okulunun kapısından içeri...
Sayıların ve harflerin gizemini öğrenmiş.
Biraz kırıkları olsa da
karnesini aldığı gün eline
sevincine diyecek yokmuş Hasan'ın.
Gitmiş koşmuş eve tam annesine
gösterecekken karnesini
fark etmiş ki bir gariplik var.
O gün ne salça kalmış evlerinde,
ne tarhana, ne ekmek.
Anası Meryem gelmiş demiş ki;
- Oğlum Hasan, görürsün
kardeşlerin bebektir bense hâlâ gebe,
senin çitin öbür tarafına gitmen gerekir.
Oradan altınlar toplaman
bize getirmen gerekir.
Hasan derin bir nefes almış.
- Peki ana, demiş.
Gitmiş çitin kenarına,
tırmanmış, öbür tarafa geçmiş.
Ertesi yıl gelmiş Hasan.
Gelmiş beraberinde de
üç tane altın getirmiş.
Çok sevinmişler,
bağırlarına basmışlar Hasanım demişler.
Hatta bir de düğün dernek yapmışlar,
evlendirmişler Hasan'ı da.
Sonra Hasan kente dönmüş.
Ertesi yıl bir kere daha gelmiş,
bu sefer cebinde iki altın.
Yine çok sevinmişler
bağırlarına basmışlar.
Yeni doğan kız çocuğunu göstermişler
onlara, adı Songül olsun demiş.
Sonra dönmüş tekrar kente,
ertesi yıl gelememiş Hasan.
Bir altın, bir mektup göndermiş.
Sonraki yıl, hiçbir şey yok.
Sonraki yıl yok, yok.
Belli ki Hasan da kaybolmuş
dipsiz sokaklarında kentin.
Ama gel zaman git zaman
buradaki Songül de büyümüş.
Songül de büyümüş, ağaçlara tırmanır,
duvardan düşer, tarlada çalışırken...
Ve o büyük gün gelmiş,
köy okulunun kapısından geçmiş.
Köy okuluna girince bir çift
gülümseyen gözle karşılaşmış gözleri.
Günaydın demiş bu gözler ona.
Sonra beraber oyun
oynamaya başlamışlar,
kahkahalar atmışlar.
Bazen düşmüş yere Songül,
kaldırmış öğretmeni,
gözlerinin içine bakmış yine
silmiş gözyaşlarını.
Hatta, öyle bir melekmiş ki bu öğretmen
bazen evlerine de gelirmiş,
sofralarına otururmuş, dinlermiş;
o gencecikken evlendirilen
ninesinin hikâyesini,
kentin sokaklarında
kaybolan babasının hikâyesini.
Bazen çınarların altında otururlar
birbirlerine masallar anlatırlarmış.
Ve evet o zaman gelmiş,
karnesini alacakmış artık Songül de.
Evet almış, o gün öğretmeni
bütün köylüleri de çağırmış.
Demiş ki artık bu çiti aşma vaktidir.
Köylüler şaşırmışlar deli mi bu ne.
Kaybolacak bu çocuklarda
kentin sokaklarında,
ne yapacaklar?
Hem ya hayvanlar çobansız kalırsa,
ya soba odunsuz kalırsa ne yaparlar.
Köylüler endişelene dursun
öğretmen açmış bile bir delik
ve çocuklar zıplamaya başlamışlar,
geçmişler tutmuşlar
yeni bir okulun yolunu.
O sırada öğretmen fark etmiş ki,
aslında tek başına değil,
orada bir öğretmen daha var,
evet evet, o gölge de bir öğretmen,
şuradaki gölge de bir öğretmen.
Aslında o kadar çokmuş ki sayıları,
birbirlerini fark etmişler,
bir araya gelmişler
ve beyaz çit devrilmiş.
Beyaz çit devrildiğinde,
beyaz çit devrildiğinde
bu taraftaki Meryemler,
Songüller, Hasanlar
açmışlar kanatlarını uçmuşlar.
Karşı taraftaki yaşıtları da
hayatlarında ilk defa
çilek gibi kokan çilekler yemiş,
yıldızların yaldızını görmüşler.
Ve beraberce saçmışlar iyilik tılsımlarını
dört bir yana, ülkenin dört bir yanına.
Ve yıllar boyunca bu masalı köylüler o
yaşlı çınarların altında anlatadurmuşlar.
Masalım bu kadar.
(Alkışlar)
Meryem'in hikâyesi de,
Hasan'ın hikâyesi de
Songül'ün hikâyesi de gerçek hikâyeler.
Hepsinin içinde benim
şimdiye kadar tanıştığım köylülerin,
öğretmenlerin, çocukların
hikâyeleri gizli.
Ve şu anda Türkiye'de;
Meryem gibi, Hasan gibi, Songül gibi
yaklaşık 5 milyon çocuk yaşıyor.
Ve o çocuklar kanatları katlı iyiliklerini
saçmak için hazır bekler vaziyetteler.
Ben şimdiye kadar gerek yurt içinde gerek
yurt dışında, 50'den fazla köyü gezdim.
Köylülerle oturdum, sohbetler ettim,
çocuklarla oynadım,
öğretmenlerle çalıştım.
Ve şimdi tüm buralardan alıp topladığım
ve böyle küçük toplar hâline getirdiğim
üç sır getirdim size.
Şimdi bu üç sırrı paylaşıp
sonra da sahneden ayrılmak istiyorum.
Birinci sırrım; sürdürülebilir kalkınma
ve köylerin ilişkisi üzerine.
Eminim siz de duymuşsunuzdur
sürdürülebilir kalkınma kavramını.
Son zamanlarda çok kullanılan bir söz.
Sürdürülebilir kalkınma; ihtiyaçlarımızı
mevcut kaynakları kullanırken
toplumsal adaleti, doğayı,
ve gelecek nesilleri de
gözeterek kalkınmak demek.
İhtiyaçlarımızı bu şekilde
karşılamak demek.
Sürdürülebilir kalkınma doğa olmadan,
dayanışma olmadan, denge olmadan olmaz.
O yüzden köyler burada
hem köylere, hem şehirlere
deva ve ilham kaynağı olabilir.
İkinci sırrıma gelince ikinci sırrım;
kırsal kalkınma ve
köy okulları ilişkisi üzerine.
Kırsal kalkınma günümüzde
daha çok şöyle anlaşılıyor:
Gidiyoruz işte, köylülere
bir miktar finansal yatırım yapıyoruz,
kaynak sağlıyoruz ya da gidiyoruz onlara
nasıl iyi çiftçilik yapılır
onu öğretiyoruz
ama bence bu hiç yeterli değil.
Bir süre bu anlayışla köyleri
biraz daha hayatta tutabiliriz belki
ama gitmek istediğimiz yer
gerçekten bu mu?
Yeterli mi?
Bence değil.
Aslında, asıl kırsal kalkınma
köylüler kendi koşullarını fark edip
kendi potansiyellerini fark edip
eyleme geçebildiklerinde başlayacak.
Ve bunu yapabilmek için de
aslında çok şeye ihtiyacımız var.
Yani sadece köylülerin değil,
hepimizin kendi
potansiyellerimizi fark edip
eyleme geçebilmemiz için
ihtiyacımız olan neler var neler.
İletişim becerisi, işbirliği kurabilmek,
kendimizi tanıyabilmek,
kendi farkındalığımız duygularımızla,
düşüncelerimizle bütünsel olarak
kendimizi bilmek,
yaratıcı düşünebilmek,
analitik olabilmek ama aynı zamanda
farklı fikirleri sentezleyebilmek...
Ve bütün bunları kazanmak için
bizim çok daha erken yaşlarda
çalışmaya başlamamız gerekiyor.
İşte o yüzden de köy okulları
çok çok önemli.
Köy okullarından vazgeçemeyiz.
Kırsaldaki koşullara uygun bütünsel,
kaliteli eğitim veren köy okullarında.
Gelelim üçüncü ve son sırrıma:
Üçüncü sırrım da köy okulları
ve öğretmenler üzerine.
Ama bence bu sırdan
hepimizin alabileceği bir şey var:
Şunu görüyorum; evet köy okullarının
çoğu çok ihtiyaç sahibi olabiliyor,
materyalleri eksik oluyor
ama inanın asıl değişimi yaratan şey
öğretmenlerin kendileri oluyor.
Bir öğretmenin bu konuya nereden
başladığı çok ama çok fark ediyor.
Siz köy okullarını;
ahh yazık işte çok fakir,
zaten eğitimde burada
çok kötü diye bakabilirsiniz.
Ya da şöyle bakabilirsiniz;
evet belli sorunlar var ama
çok da önemli fırsatlar var.
Akran eğitimi için çok uygun burası.
Doğaya yakın, ailelere yakın,
çocuklara yakın, sınıf mevcudu az.
Ve biz bu fırsatları
fark edip baktığımızda
gerçekten çok şey değişiyor.
Gerçekten ama gerçekten,
sizin bir olaya nereden
baktığınız çok şeyi değiştiriyor.
Ve tabii ki değişimi
tek başımıza yaratamıyoruz,
orada da ilişkiler devreye giriyor.
Öğretmen - öğretmen arasındaki ilişkiler,
öğretmen - öğrenci arasındaki ilişkiler,
öğretmen - aile arasındaki ilişkiler,
şehirden gelen gönüllü ile
öğretmen arasındaki ilişkiler,
bizim aramızdaki ilişkiler.
Değişim, birinin zihnine ve kalbine
dokunabildiğiniz zaman başlıyor.
Şimdi lütfen bu sırları düşünün,
bu sırlar sizin hayatınızda
nereye oturuyor?
Siz bu masalın neresindesiniz?
Çitin hangi tarafındasınız?
Olduğunuz yerden memnun musunuz?
Çitin öbür tarafında kalan insanların
olduğu yerden memnun musunuz?
Bu çiti beraber devirmek ister misiniz?
Teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkışlar)